Oh
living planet is a company that has
developed the most interesting
innovative radical business model I've
seen for creating new sustainable cities
and for retrofitting existing cities to
improve their performance there are
various tag lines that are used for new
cities some people call them smart
cities some people call them green
cities there's nuance of those what
living planet is doing for its pilot
project is creating a research city so
it's a city where the economic model is
based on research and innovation that
will be the economic driver it is being
built to the highest standards of
sustainability defined in terms of
environmental issues social issues
governance issues but it's not a green
city per se the way I think you could
say Masdar is so it has a strong and
viable economic model the the current
title for this city your name for the
city is planted Valley it is being built
on sixteen hundred and seventy hectares
of land in the municipality of parish
which is outside Porto about 20 minutes
outside Porto there's this remarkable
man named celso Ferrara who is the
president of pêche like Steve and
Malcolm is a visionary the way these
people all found each other is an
interesting story has been very
supportive so there's a strong
relationship between the company and the
Portuguese government both at the
municipality level the regional level
and the national level though it's not
in the classic sense a public-private
partnership because all of the funding
that is being done is coming from the
private sector and they will begin
building this as they say one point 0
because their software guys it's a
software metaphor planet Valley this
year and the intention is to then
replicate this model all over the world
we're clearly the the major markets from
a new cities point of view where many
new cities have to be built
emerging markets such as China and India
and Brazil the foundation of their
business model is an ecosystem of a
variety of companies including
technology companies Cisco is is one of
the key partners in this and they're
they're working out the business model
with them I have a Harvard Business
School teaching case which describes the
business model describes who some of the
partners are they're involved and for my
research on sustainable organization
that I'm doing with professor Amy
Edmondson who is a colleague of mine
here at Harvard Business School Living
Planet the company and then planet
Valley the project are our baseline sort
of research sites right now and we'll be
studying that over time and then and
then looking to study other so-called
smart cities or green cities there's a
place called New Songdo in Korea there's
Masdar and Abu Dhabi which I mentioned
there's a city that's now kind of on
hold for political reasons called dong
tan and China so this area of
sustainable urbanization is an
incredibly it's an important issue and
it's it's a big market opportunity the
issue around sustainable urbanization
and a part of living planets business
plan is a radically different approach
to construction the construction
industry has showed negative
productivity growth thirty to fifty
percent of the materials are wasted
forty percent of carbon emissions come
from buildings if these new cities are
built the way the old cities have been
built the process doesn't contribute to
sustainability the outcome doesn't
contribute to sustainability so a key
part of their business model is a
radical new approach to building and
construction on which they've developed
intellectual properties so that's an
important part to cover as well it's
interesting to note thinking about our
previous discussion and integrated
reporting that living planet as it gets
established as committing to publish a
integrated report there a private
company they're under no pressure to do
so and all the partners of living planet
and planet Valley will also be producing
integrated report so there's a clear
conceptual linkage between
sustainable urbanization and an
integrated reporting and for for anybody
that's interested in sustainable
urbanization and the impact of the built
environment on the planet i think that
following and understanding what living
planet and and i know those are doing i
think is a an important interesting and
useful thing to do
cities are being rebuilt all the time I
think the notion of quote tearing down
existing cities and building them from
scratch clearly you know isn't a
practical one but there's a question
about I talked about this with my
students my MBAs when I taught the case
my doctoral students existing cities the
so-called urban retrofit market could be
an even bigger opportunity it would be
approached in a somewhat different way
but the the services the products the
technologies the sensor technology and
in particular core aspect of the Living
Planet business model something they
call the urban operating system could be
used in existing urban environments as
well as it is in in new cities so the
basic notion is that you go into
existing urban environments incorporate
the new technologies smart buildings
smart grid mobility look at the
information in an integrated way in
terms of how the city is functioning
economically and socially and
environmentally in a way that would
improve performance and i can tell you
and i can't give you the names but right
now living planet is talking to existing
cities this is a major area of focus for
cisco and there is interested in
existing urban environments as they are
new urban environments and so just as as
planet valley will hopefully become a
showcase for how to build new
sustainable cities there will be one or
two existing cities and there's some
fairly major in prominent cities that
they're in discussion with now that
could become models for how to use these
new technologies in this new way of
thinking to create more sustainable
urban environments the other thing i
should note and it's relevant to both
existing urban environments and new
urban environments what's interesting
about their business model is that it is
not primarily a real estate development
play and that's been the case so far
people say none of these new towns none
of these experiments none of these smart
cities green cities have been successful
and I think that's largely true and
that's true because the
business model that has been used as a
real estate development try and get the
land cheap have deep pockets you know
build it you know Lisa sell it it's the
classic thing that happens you have a
couple of guys with an extraordinary
team of people from all over the world
really and it's a longer story than I
can get into you're here it's in my case
but they've come at a problem through a
different lens so they're looking at a
problem really through the lens of the
software industry and so they're framing
the problem they're framing the
opportunity in a different way clearly
there's real estate there's real estate
development and that's being
incorporated into it but they've just
kind of looked at it in a different way
and I think they've come up with
something very interesting and very
creative and an example of that right
now here we are in Boston over the last
two or three days the Urban Land
Institute has had one of their I think
they meet by annually so this is real
estate developers from all over the
world one of the main sponsors for the
uli conference taking place in Boston
this week is cisco IBM is very focused
on smart cities Oracle has developed
software for smart cities Siemens has a
number of products and services for
smart cities so you can see major
corporations have identified this
opportunity what living planet has come
up with is a business model that
integrates the capabilities of all of
these different companies through this
ecosystem and then the representation or
the the integration really of the
technologies that these other firms have
through the urban operating system is
that in a sense some kind of mental
mental kind of the UM it's like the
nervous system is probably the best way
to think about it the nervous system for
what will will make these cities be
sustainable broadly defined sustainable
not simply in environmental terms but in
social quality of life and financial
terms as well